Hey Nina, what’s up?
Hey, Tom, real quick. The 20th anniversary of
the Harry Potter movies just happened, and so —
And you want a quick synopsis of the stories!
No, I…
No problem! Fights Voldemort, fights Voldemort,
hangs out with his dad’s friend from
high school that just got out of jail,
fights Voldemort, fights Voldemort,
Dumbledore eats it, fights Voldemort.
Okay, that’s not technically wrong, but -
Look, I can go into more detail.
Please don’t.
But it’s going to take a while and I
don’t know if you’ll be able to keep up.
I read all of the books once a year.
I know so much more than you do.
We’ll start with Harry’s infancy.
Oh, f—.
It is a dark time for Wizard kind, as the evil
lord Voldemort has become what sorcerers refer to as a Jerk McGurk.
Ah yes, the Jerk McGurk who must not be named.
A prophecy states that Voldemort
will be defeated by some kid -
Oversimplification.
So he decides to kill baby
Harry by feeding him to a snake.
Nope.
By chucking him out a window.
No.
By un-baby proofing the Potter house
and letting him toddle into corners.
No, he uses magic.
He uses magic to try to stop
a prophecy? Isn’t that sort of like
begging for ironic narrative retribution?
I don’t know what to tell you. Every baby looks
like a nail when all you’ve got is a magic hammer.
A hammer would have worked.
MOVING ON.
Because Harry’s mom sacrifices herself to save
him, Harry is granted powerful magical protection.
That's correct.
Just like how that secret service
agent died protecting President
Truman and now he's our immortal,
bulletproof president for life.
Sure.
Voldemort gets turned into a problem for later.
Also, Harry winds up with some of Voldemort’s soul
in his tummy. So now he can talk to snakes.
Oh, and his forehead glows when orcs are near.
Close enough.
Harry grows up with his aunt and uncle and cousin,
who are the bad guys from every Roald Dahl book,
until his 11th birthday, when he finds out
that he has magic powers and goes shopping
for a stick that shoots fire and can kill
people. Then it's off to elementary school.
Book one ends with Harry and his friends doing the
British version of Legends of the Hidden Temple
and Harry fighting the back of his teacher's head.
Mmhmm.
Book two is a classic murder mystery where the
culprit is a racist snake. Book three is a classic
British time travel caper in the tradition of
Doctor Who, and the worst episodes of Doctor Who.
This is also the book where the fans get upset
when they find out that the rat that Ron has
been sharing a bed with for years was actually
a middle-aged man. But what they never seem to
mention is whether it would have been less weird
if he’d just been sleeping next to a regular rat. Right?
Yeah, marginally less weird.
Book four marks an important
tonal shift for Harry. After
being chosen to compete in what’s
essentially the magic Olympics…
Let me stop you right there. The Triwizard
Tournament is not the magic Olympics.
Okay, what would you compare it to?
It’s more like the wizard NCAA, only there’s
a chance that the athletes might actually get paid.
Got it. Anyway, Harry watches as Ron’s old pet rat
turns his classmate Cedric
Diggory into Deadric Diggory.
Ugh.
He turns him into a Grave Diggor-y.
UGH
Into Deadric Grave Diggory Dead Murder Dead
Please Stop.
Voldemort comes back, first as an angry little
baby then as a long, white jelly bean.
Great.
In year five, Harry learns that government
oversight is bad and that starting a fight
club at school is good. Meanwhile,
Voldemort hears the first half of a prophecy
about himself and gets all self conscious,
so he gaslights Harry into
visiting a snowglobe factory.
Yeah… wait, what?
And then Harry finds out that he’s half
dracula, but then my dad shows up and
he's all like "You’re the reason your mom left.”
Then after that Pete Davidson takes his pants...
Tom.
What?
You fell asleep during the movie.
Yeahhh...
That makes more sense. Where was I?
Giving me an aneurysm?
Year six is a tough one, because in the
books it’s an exploration of trauma and
betrayal and their effects on young people,
whereas in the movie, Harry does kissing.
And attempted homicide.
Also, the teacher that Harry
thought was bad turns out to be bad.
Okay. Perfect. Go on.
In the last book, Harry and his friends do a
scavenger hunt for wads of Voldemort’s soul. Also,
the teacher that Harry thought was bad that turned
out to be bad turned out to not be bad at all,
just super-duper horny for Harry’s mom.
Always.
Voldemort dies of a flaky peely sunburn,
everyone marries someone that they went to
high school with, and the story is over.
What about The Cursed Child?
Rupert Grint? First of all, he's not cursed, he just has red hair.
Never mind.
So there you have it. The story
of a bullied young white boy who grew
up to become a cop and get his
best friend’s sister pregnant.
Look, you’re not wrong, but that’s
not why I called. I already know
all of this. In fact, I know way more than this.
So wait, you knew everything that was
being said but you sat through it anyway,
even though you were just getting bored and mad?
Yeah. Fans call that “the
Fantastic Beasts effect.”
Ok, why did you call?
I wanted to see if I could borrow your
Gryffindor robes, I'm going to a costume party.
Oh, uh, those are still at the dry cleaner.
Wait, why?
No reason.